Visia how far does Europe have to tear
itself apart to stay together that's
where I'll discuss now with martin
short's president of the european
parliament welcome thank you a warm
welcome to the DW interview my name is
Thomas pond mr. Schwartz what do you
like most about Alexis tsipras some Club
and nearly shaman I think he's an honest
man he's making a strong effort to
implement the program he put forward as
cearense a leader and in doing so he's
running into the limitations that are
placed on him as Greek Prime Minister
help me administer Gazette's them he has
not really internalized this yet but the
fact remains that he is in my eyes a
pretty honest person puts even the early
show just so you admire him because he's
fighting for a hard-line position and
that's why his voters elected him he's
basically a tough cookie just like his
voters wanted one who represents their
interests the wooden toys you nisht I
don't admire him there's something but
not because I sometimes do not
understand him of course he defends the
interests of his voters the question is
does he really defend those who voted
for syriza his party or the Greek people
as a whole and I think his prime
minister of his country he has to
account for the consequences of his
stubbornness here sundus by the hot non
which often have ideological
underpinnings is bath vin is green done
but on the other hand if Greece fails to
negotiate a fair compromise anti-stress
fair compromise Greece will face dark
times Finn's taan-son to me let's talk
about fairness we see a state that wants
to be able to feast and it wants for
others to pay for that feast it wasn't
an outsider who said that but lithuanian
president da da Grabowski attack didn't
she just described the core problem
what he fina destino I find a radical
rhetoric of daria grievous kata totally
inappropriate she hasn't just done this
with Greece but on other issues I have
nothing against clear words but here she
says something that is just not right
for it may be that the Greek lawmakers
wanted Greece to feast over the last 30
to 40 years well but Tsaritsa has had
just six months in office the current
government has had the least
responsibility for the Greek malaise
until now it was always in opposition
mr. shorts he could have changed things
he could have collected more tax revenue
put the country back on track boost the
economy since I could have done all this
already yet exactly I'll say it again 40
years earlier other governments built up
a mountain of problems sir it's a can't
demolish this in six months visa means X
Mona and that is why I'm is Grievous
qaeda's criticism is not justified some
criticism is justified namely what you
just mentioned they have lost six months
if they'd focused less on ideological
debates and more on pregnant ism this
would already have enabled them to
overcome a lot of problems but it's also
about the attitude that Greece exudes
there's another voice that's perhaps not
as isolated as that of miserable sky
tonight IMF chef Christine lagasse's she
wanted to engage in dialogue with adults
and not children I interpret this as
some are treating the negotiations as a
poker game while others including you or
taking Greece very seriously is that
something that you agree with a male
suspect I'm you see what stuff so that's
our problem to some extent are we
actually dealing with serious people who
want to make serious compromises and
work toward them or are we dealing with
game theorists like mr. varoufakis I can
only repeat I am open to serious
compromises and I know Jean Claude yoker
and the others are too
is the Greek government going to keep
playing its hand because it knows it
will have to pay in the end I think the
government is making a serious mistake
for which the Greek people and not the
players will ultimately pay van we've
seen through their comments that some
people get hot under the collar even if
they do dress it up in pleasant words
would mind of all to Clyde but at some
point the attitude of the Greek
negotiators must get on your nerves do
you now thinking they still act as if
Europe is trying to get money from
Greece and not vice versa doesn't this
make you lose your patience let's see
let's take our you know I know I'm dr.
Felson phone I said on German television
a few days ago that I'd had enough of us
just like everybody else that's a stick
but of course I won't lose my patience
politics doesn't work like this on a
national level nevermind international
we need to work with great patience in
Europe certainly we've experienced
others who have SAT here and said if I
don't get what I want and I'll bring
everything to a standstill luckily
having Gunson on the stuff on an incline
for going on there is nice little drama
TV reason although of Yahoo we once had
to break off a meeting because an
italian prime minister said if his
country did not get a 750 first seat in
the european parliament he would not
vote Denise elusive we've dealt with
nonsense like this already you have to
have steady nerves in European politics
but when everything is at stake and
everything is at stake for Greece you
need calm nerves and sang fois we now
the nod would cut this booth in Oman I'm
assuming your attentions are honorable
when it comes to Athens oh no Meah a
nasty one you want europe which overcame
trench warfare and hostilities not to be
torn apart sweetie freshman Abba East us
but does that justify blackmail facile
including from the Greek side as a fun
desire to King Lance doesn't have to
formally oh that's a tough formulation
you've chose
there but I don't feel blackmailed by
Greece in my opinion sir Itza is not
very smart or particularly skilled when
it comes to negotiation but in one point
it is right I don't think ms Lagarde's
proposal to raise v80 on medicines is
helpful in a country where one-third of
the population is not covered by the
medical system I think it would be
sensible of Greek cut its military
spending in relation to GDP they spend
more in their military than Germany does
there's room to slim down this is not
about blackmail we have to find
pragmatic ways to get past the
ideologues there are ideologues on all
sides not just radical leftist
ideologues in government in Athens but
also radical free-market ideologues here
during the last few years within the
so-called troika I heard lots of
proposals that made me furious what
we've got to do now is find a compromise
the first step is to reform Greece
redevelop sustainably over the long term
let's talk about what drives you
personally you're a passionate Social
Democrat and Europeans you grew up in a
border region and you were awarded the
Charlemagne prize how important is
justice to you because the question of
justice decides the welfare not only of
nation states but also of transnational
democracy we live in a Europe where
speculators can make billions in profits
and not pay a penny in taxes and if you
make billions your losses the taxpayers
cover the question of justice is the
core policy area in which I feel at home
so means the boutique in there HP stalls
of him bendis if that's true then you
also need to offer special conditions to
Ireland Portugal Spain and Cyprus just
like those being talked about for Greece
right please dude that's right we gave
those countries billions in assistance
the difference between them and grease
is that their governments offered us
much stronger cooperation and as a
result these countries gradually emerged
from the crisis thick visa we must also
tell the series of government plainly at
the end of last year
summer espheni zealous Greece had its
first budget surplus and slight growth
for the first time like this box this
has been frittered away in the past six
months if you have five well-behaved
members of a family and you have one
who's now out of line what do you do
break up the family punish all of them
even those who behave well or just the
one who's harming the family what does
on zadi media sometimes you just can't
live together anymore no in a family you
don't throw your kids out it happens you
don't show your kids out if you want to
hold the family together or only as a
last resort not as long as you still see
hope that things can get better I was no
use I'm zahab but I have to agree with
the point many critics make especially
in Portugal and Greece when I asked
quiet Greece is being treated better
than they were well this is something
that we say to mr. tipper us every day
hun see [ __ ] eaten talk so I'm up his
language so far with very little success
is the reason for this endless wrangling
because so far there hasn't been anyone
and certainly not any German who's
willing to tell Greece that's enough
fans act is raised get meat got a
baguette don't get this list that's not
what this is about I don't know when you
were last in assets this is a European
Union member where there are soup
kitchens something missing stock good
Muslim I think we are strong enough to
solve the problem we don't have to throw
them out we can keep them in the problem
is that we have to deal with the
government that was voted in because the
people at these soup kitchens are
desperate I can understand this
government to some extent we have to see
the social pressures that they're under
but they must also see that the EU can
work only if everyone complies with its
rules in politics everyone can turn to
reason when they look into the abyss and
my feeling is they are about to look
into exactly this abyss as Sen France my
Navajo mango fiestas inserts a toboggan
odisa napkin Susie some Josephine at the
end as always in the DW interview we
have three
unfinished sentences that will ask you
to complete I find the image of Greeks
who have become used to living off
benefits wrong by anything because it's
not the Greeks on social benefits have
been spoiled but the country's elite
with its privileges of Jeff convince
wolfgang schreiber and Yanis varoufakis
to sit down together for a beer I would
even have someone else had be better at
that face na manha after my first
meeting with cheapest in Athens
following his election victory and you
were one of the first who was there I
was hopeful that doesn t Hat's bet he
wouldn't come to Brussels asere it's a
leader but as Greek Prime Minister that
he has not done he arrived here as party
leader the style of party leaders not in
the style of government but that's
changed he threw Stephens league young
Chefs the Stasi other things his skin
how did you have any hope that he'll
ultimately overcome this position and
reach out to the Europeans hello Bootsie
possible I believe that tsipras will
ultimately even throw all his own
political weight behind trying to find a
compromise for the benefit of his home
country so how's the deutsche to become
Martin Schultz thank you very much thank
you